body camera video shows the disturbing
treatment of an unstable Woman by
Tennessee police officers all this
before she collapses in police custody
and later dies
hold on
just before 8 o'clock in the morning on
February 5th officers in Knoxville
Tennessee got a call about a woman who
refused to leave the Fort Sanders
Regional Medical Center even though
she'd already been released from
treatment
I asked you to leave didn't he well did
the hospital ask you to leave
and all they said they want you to leave
yeah
you got to leave though they want you
gone video shows a first responder
speaking with a woman later identified
as 60 year old Lisa Edwards
no they want you gone
you can't get where
you can't get to where
they don't want you back up there they
want you to leave their property
they want you to leave their property
ma'am
can I what
you got to go somewhere the officer
repeatedly tells Edwards there's no need
for her to go to jail but that she must
leave Hospital property
you're gonna have to figure something
out
cause ain't no need for you to go to
jail over some nonsense but you gotta
leave Edwards says she was mistreated by
Hospital staff and cannot physically
leave well I don't who beat you up
[Applause]
so the people in the hospital beat you
up last night
well they said they want you gone so you
gotta go this is their property
why can't you walk
[Applause]
hi
your ankle shattered and they kick you
out
officers continue to ask Edwards to
leave the hospital grounds ma'am ma'am
what's your name
okay Miss Edwards they said you have
already talked to the doctor and then
you've listened to me I'm talking you've
already talked to the doctor you've
already been discharged from the
hospital they want you gone I I I'm
talking I understand you say you got
some problems going on you're gonna have
to find a way to get out of here okay I
don't want this to turn into a situation
where you have to go to jail eventually
officers decide Edwards will be taken
into custody on a trespassing charge you
said in the lobby for 30 minutes and you
had to fall and you put it back down you
did not use the phone you did not even a
tip to use the phone to make a phone
call
[Applause]
the police
we tried to find a piece of resolution
you're the one that wanted us to call
no more
okay I'm done talking to him you started
talking nonsense like that I'm done with
you go to jail multiple First Responders
then work to lift Edwards into a vehicle
that would transport her to jail all
right young lady
we're happy okay
it's not scrapped in there
oh yeah I am my bag
my bag oh no please
officers continue to work with Edwards
as she's unable to get inside the
vehicle they repeat that she has been
medically cleared to leave there you go
you can
go right there
right there
if you get in there
oh my God
listen you're gonna have to get up there
because we're gonna have to physically
put you up there if not and that's not
as nice so please help us help you
oh my God you've been medically cleared
so let's get in let's stop okay it's not
working okay just stop okay we're not
doing this so we're gonna put you back
there we're not doing this no more with
you so quit we've been medical cleared
so we know better officers also refuse
to take Edwards to a different medical
facility now
yeah
I don't know don't touch me I'm tired of
this is ridiculous
I see why you got kicked out of two
Hospitals now
okay
well the hospital already said things
taking you back we're not taking you to
another one video then shows AdWords
with slurred speech seemingly having
breathing problems help us help you
oh my God you've been medically cleared
so let's get in
hey please no I can't use yes ma'am
you're gonna have to get it
because you're you've been medically
cleared man this is not going to work so
we need you to help us
but you need to get in there
right there
I'm having these freezing problems
they're there when you're out here
smoking a cigarette
I don't know where the top is
oh God
at one point Edwards Falls over during
the interaction
now step up now okay yes you can or I'm
gonna put you in there now get in there
on my head
all right
officers can be heard saying that they
are struggling to get Edwards inside the
vehicle eventually they become
frustrated and yell at her I can't pick
her up because she's dead wait she's not
getting her damn legs she's not healthy
you come to him this is not mine
okay
this is the Lord listen to me this is
the Lord say all I want to do is give me
some confidence and oatmeal I'm not
going to deal with your mess this
morning we've already spent too much
time
you're gonna get up here in this vein
you're going to go to jail we're done
with you
okay yeah
yeah I know that's that's the whole
problem
well you know what well don't get in
there and finish out with your numbers
but this is all the ACT that's all it is
going with you you're not taking you
back in the hospital unless you've been
kicked out of two hospitals
what do you need for
you I have one in there we've already
went first
this is a portion of your inhaler is
missing
plasters
okay so listen this is gonna be your
eyes you're gonna get up and you're
gonna sit here I'm gonna stuff you in
the floor so which one do you want it to
be
I'm leaving it up to you you either get
your butt up here or you're gonna have
your head there and your feet here and
we're gonna put some noise gonna drive
the jail like this
[Music]
oh my God
you're about to happen you're about to
get some more charges that's what's
about to happen Okay you get it back
quit coming out
try to get her back that way
oh
yeah
what's in the back Danny
you think we get her in the back easier
yeah
and
it read
s you so round but I'm thinking one of
us could back in I want us to grab
blower which is in there I don't be able
to get her out
so I have to dry ground
hey bud it's all the portion open with
the lock on the other side no this is it
yeah I thought that would open it now so
we can sneak out and drag her in yeah
hey Brandon come here and look at the
back and see what you think
if something happens
thank you
listen you're going to get jammed in a
tiny compartment if you don't get up
there man listen to me listen
get up there and quit with this bull
crap
and we're gonna Jam you in those spots
smaller we're trying to help you here
get in there it's bigger and you're by
yourself
at one point Edwards ends up on the
ground in front of the vehicle
Edwards then asks for an inhaler saying
she cannot breathe
oh my gosh
that's it
I can't breathe I need to get like
ma'am your views are inhaler three times
if anybody had let you die to yourself
because you weren't using it the correct
way
it's all on camera right here but you
use that inhaler and blowing it out it's
then that multiple officers lift Edwards
into a squad car
oh no my leg
s
I know
yeah
in here
okay hold on bro
okay
video from inside the squad car shows
the same moment from another angle okay
hold on bro
okay okay
once inside the vehicle Edwards
continues to complain about breathing
problems and can be heard wheezing
my games are like this
open the door
hurry up with me
I can't believe
okay
I can't breathe
oh yeah
I guess it's free
after that officers work to resituate
her in the squad's back seat you pulled
yourself to
yeah yeah
sit up okay
come on slide over here officer Timothy
distasio eventually drives off with
Edwards in the back seat
I'm here
again
yeah some situation he can be heard
checking in on AdWords during the trip
how you doing back there okay
thank you
at one point officer distasio stops the
squad for an unrelated traffic stop it's
then that he finds Edwards unresponsive
I don't
know hey come on sit up
can you arrive before
I don't know if she's faking it or what
but she's not answering me I don't know
if she's faking it or what but she's not
answering
the Knoxville police chief has since
said he was quote Disturbed and
embarrassed after watching the videos a
formal review found the officers
involved either inadequately addressed
Edwards as health concerns or blatantly
ignored them
according to the Knox County District
Attorney's Office edwards's official
cause of death was a stroke none of the
officers involved will face criminal
charges but all four were placed on paid
administrative leave after the incident
though none of them will lose their jobs
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie